good evening everybody all of you know
Ray Dalio as one of the most
accomplished investors of our time and
his firm Bridgewater associates as the
largest and most successful hedge fund
in the world well you may not know about
ray his three decades of personal
business and philanthropic experience in
China
his knowledge affection and respect for
the Chinese culture and people have led
to a real understanding of China and
many deep and intimate friendships Ray's
relationship with China has been a
family affair that began 35 years ago
when Ray was invited to teach economics
and financial markets
he went out of curiosity and brought his
family along they were immediately
struck by the people they met and who
cared for them their warmth and their
kindness they found a country
underdeveloped economically but a
culture highly advanced over the years
ray came back again and again supporting
China's leadership as they began
building their financial system in fact
he hoped to establish their first stock
exchange Ray's family came back as well
they immersed themselves in Chinese
culture and education Ray's son attended
local Chinese schools the family formed
a deep affection for the people coupled
with a natural desire to support them
when he was a teenager Ray's son visit
her local orphanage and finding it
filled with physically handicapped
children he learned that many could be
healed for as little as five hundred
dollars he took it upon himself to raise
70 thousand back home
since then the Dalio family has raised
many millions to help
special-needs orphans in China today
Bridgewater manages investments and
provides advice to the country's leading
institutions and senior policymakers the
good work of Ray and his family's
philanthropic activities provided
through the China Care Foundation the
Beijing Dalio Foundation and the China
global Phil in philanthropy Institute
raised personal journey with China and
the many trusted relationships he has
built with senior leadership have made a
contribution towards improving the
knowledge and understanding between the
Chinese and American people a
contribution that aligns closely with
the mission of the National Committee as
you all know our country's relationship
today with China is marked by deep
strategic distrust and a lack of
meaningful high-level communication both
countries have constituents that view
the other is a threat or even as an
enemy an advocate advocate for this.for
disengagement these notions are growing
in popularity and in my judgment are
misguided and take us in the wrong
direction with the People's Republic of
China recently recognizing its 70th
anniversary our two nations shared
history in many important respects would
suggest otherwise
cooperation and engagement have
benefited both our nation's the US
business community wants engagement not
decoupling we seek cooperation and
healthy competition while we each
dispense
defend our respective national interests
we want negotiations that lead to
substantive agreement now comes not
tariffs we don't support a trade war as
a strategy
we want to compete but insist we do so
on a level playing field with that I am
delighted to present the National
Committee on us-china relations 2019
gala honoree Ray Dalio
[Applause]
I'm so pretty incredibly in all the
people who were in this room you know
some have been mentioned dr. Kissinger
Carla Hills Steve Orleans but there are
many many many many more so on very
humbled to be here and the way I think
of we each have perspectives but it's a
little bit like the parable of the blind
man and the elephant you know we each
touch a little bit of art of China and
we all have opinions and maybe too many
opinions and there's a lot of argument
about what the right opinions are and I
can't say what the right opinions are I
can only share the perspective that I've
acquired and so whether it's right or
wrong I don't know but it's been my
perspective I was lucky enough to go to
China in 1984 so 35 years ago as a guest
of acidic and which was the only window
company at the time that was the only
company that could look at the outside
world and deal with the outside world
you know at that time I would bring as a
gift
$10 calculators to people who ran
companies and they thought they were
miraculous machines and I remember
sitting us giving a lecture to teach
them about the financial markets on the
10th floor of the chocolate building and
to look out on the chocolate building
and there were all the hutongs that were
down there and then to imagine what
China would be like because China was
opening up so I could see that the world
was here in cost and this and China was
here and there was going to be an
opening up in the world would change as
a result of that opening up so I looked
out on the hutongs and when I looked at
the hutongs and said this is going to
change you know they said you don't know
China and I said no cave I don't know
that there's globalization and who knows
what would
and since then china's income levels
have increased by twenty six times its
share of world GDP went from two percent
to 22 percent now on its poverty rate
went from over eighty eight percent to
less than one percent its life
expectancy increased by ten years
there's no greater miracle than has
happened in China not been in the
fortunate position to know the Chinese
people many people who have become
thirty-year type of friendships and then
I was able to see things and so I can
only describe what it is through my eyes
it's to me the perspectives are
different and one of the leaders
described to me that the essence of that
difference as in the United States but
the United States is a country of
individuals and individualism and it
treasures the individual it treasures
the revolutionary individual the Steve
Jobs type of personality who will
disrupt the system and so on and in
China it is the family and as an
extension of the family the collective
and he described that the word country
consists of two words - two characters
which is state family and that there's a
top-down system and there were different
core values as much in that's the same
but there is also a different
perspective and that perspective then
gets reflected in some of the
differences in the conflicts that we see
the issue is the ability to see things
through each other's eyes I've been very
lucky to be dealing with particularly
economic policymakers so that I could
see things through their eyes and of
course economics has also shifted to
geopolitics and by being able to see
things through their eyes I would say
that by and large I would be doing the
same sort of economic policies that
they've done and that if I was to look
for
the long-term in terms of productivity
and the like and the things that are
happening in the way of innovation that
entrepreneurship creativity in these
types of things the reforms but we're
going through a particular period of
time to where there was a debt
adjustment and how to manage that
sometimes it seems that a that when you
do healthy things in coentrão and
constraining the debt that it is a lot
less fun and a lot more painful than
when you have a great time getting into
debt so there are these types of
adjustments that are that that are being
made as I look at this my responsibility
is a an economic investor a global Mecca
nama kin Wester is to try to find what
are the elements that make countries
succeed and fail and to do that over
time
and that's led me to develop indicators
and literally quantify those indicators
into leading economic indicators for the
well-being in my study of watching why
reserve currencies and the countries
behind them have risen and declined with
the help of my fabulous research team
we've been able to look through times
those are arcs those along arcs in other
words there's the US as the existing
world's reserve currency before that
there was the British Empire before that
there was the Dutch Empire and these
things take place over long periods of
time a hundred two hundred years many of
those we can't see but yet they take us
by surprise like the change in the
reserve currency and the factors that we
see over a period of time in terms of
the indicators that we put together are
I'll describe it and brief indicators
first of education and civility the
better the education and the more the
civility of the behavior of people
together infrastructure infrastructure
is a good leading indicator and then
technology the invention of new
technologies technology
is not only a commercial asset it is a
military asset the capacity to build
technology is leading indicator for
example you know when the Dutch invented
ships that can go all around the world
and they carried guns and because in
Europe they fought a lot then they were
able to account for half of world trade
Holland because of the importance of
technology then you get improvements in
output GDP Rises and then you have
larger and larger shares of world trade
it's a reflection of the competitiveness
of how that arises over a period of time
because you grow because you're
competitive and you raise those living
standards and as you go globally it's
the development of the military because
you need the military to both protect
your trade routes and also to protect
the natural resources and then with that
there's always the development of a
financial system the financial hub you
know in the Dutch Empire was Amsterdam
then it was London then it was New York
and increasingly it will be Shanghai and
this is an evolution and with that
there's the development of a reserve
currency because it is the medium by
which there is a common currency and a
common exchange rate and when that
exists it also means that those
countries can get deeper into debt
because everyone wants to save in the
currency and you set your lent that
currency and then they get deeper in
debt and the economies get overextended
and that is sort of the history of the
rise and declines of vampires and
there's a certain destiny that happens
as a result of that and I want to share
with you just a couple of slides this
first chart shows that these indicators
applied to all the major empires
starting around 1500 so you could see
the rises and declines of each of those
empires this is the average of these
indicators and I think it helps to give
me perspective and I hope it gives
perspective because you can see that red
line is the red line of China and what
you see is not only a rise
at a strong pace but you also see where
China was in the relative importance
throughout history China was for most of
its history the most important or one of
the most important empires in the world
for ahead of Europe inventing the
printing press 500 years ahead and so on
and it is because of an approach it is
not an American approach it's not
democracy it's not but it is an approach
it's their approach a Confucian approach
it has to do with the way that they're
operating and so there are things that
make Americans American and there are
things that make Chinese Chinese and we
can't ever expect that we're going to
make the Chinese like Americans and to
adopt our system any more than they
should expect that Americans should be
made like Chinese and so as we have that
type of competition I'll I'll take you
back just we took it back to the Tong
dynasty so there's a tremendous culture
and a tremendous capability in history
that has to do with what what they exist
and so it is with great admiration I
have great admiration for the Chinese a
different system and with that on there
are Wars we you I don't like the word
war rather than negotiations but there
is you know there's a trade war there's
a technology war there is a geopolitical
war and there could be capital Wars and
that is the nature of the environment
and how that's approached is going to
determine what our futures are like and
I honestly don't know how it will be
approached we want to be optimistic but
as Graham Allison who was here tonight
described in his Thucydides trap there's
a certain destiny to the two arguing
about those things and not a global
world legal system that gets us through
those things so when I look at it I hope
that it is done with mutual
understanding that instead of wars which
mean lose-lose relationships that we
approach this with win-win relationships
by seeing each other through each
other's eyes and not expecting the
others to be
like us in all respects and which we
evolved through time so anyway I'm done
thank you very much for this great honor
I appreciate it very much
[Applause]